We now look at an example
similar to the previous one,
in which we have again two
scenarios, but in which we
have both discrete
and continuous
random variables involved.
You have $1 and the opportunity
to play in the lottery.
With probability 1/2, you do
nothing and you're left with
the dollar that you
started with.
With probability 1/2, you decide
to play the lottery.
And in that case, you get back
an amount of money which is
random and uniformly
distributed
between zero and two.
Is the random variable,
X, discrete?
The answer is no, because
it takes values on
a continuous range.
Is the random variable,
X, continuous?
The answer is no, because the
probability that X takes the
value of exactly one
is equal to 1/2.
Even though X takes values in
a continuous range, this is
not enough to make it a
continuous random variable.
We defined continuous random
variables to be those that can
be described by a PDF.
And you have seen it in such a
case, any individual point
should have zero probability.
But this is not the case here,
and so X is not continuous.
We call X a mixed
random variable.
More generally, we can have a
situation where the random
variable X with some probability
is the same as a
particular discrete random
variable, and with some other
probability it is equal
to some other
continuous random variable.
Such a random variable, X, does
not have a PMF because it
is not discrete.
Also, it does not have a PDF
because it is not continuous.
How do we describe such
a random variable?
Well, we can describe it in
terms of a cumulative
distribution function.
CDFs are always well
defined for all
kinds of random variables.
We have two scenarios, and
so we can use the Total
Probability Theorem and write
that the CDF is equal to the
probability of the first
scenario, which is p, times
the probability that the random
variable Y is less than
or equal to x.
This is a conditional model
under the first scenario.
And with some probability, we
have the second scenario.
And under that scenario, X will
take a value less than
little x, if and only if our
random variable Z will take a
value less than little x.
Or in CDF notation, this is p
times the CDF of the random
variable Y evaluated at this
particular x plus another
weighted term involving the CDF
of the random variable Z.
We can also define the expected
value of X in a way
that is consistent with the
Total Expectation Theorem,
namely define the expected
value of X to be the
probability of the first
scenario, in which case X is
discrete times the expected
value of the associated
discrete random variable, plus
the probability of the second
scenario, under which X is
continuous, times the expected
value of the associated
continuous random variable.
Going back to our original
example, we have two
scenarios, the scenarios that
we can call A1 and A2.
Under the first scenario, we
have a uniform PDF, and the
corresponding CDF
is as follows.
It's flat until zero, then
it rises linearly.
And then it stays flat,
and the value
here is equal to one.
So the slope here is 1/2.
So the slope is equal to
the corresponding PDF.
Under the second scenario, we
have a discrete, actually a
constant random variable.
And so the CDF is flat at zero
until this value, and at that
value we have a jump
equal to one.
We then use the Total
Probability Theorem, which
tells us that the CDF of the
mixed random variable will be
1/2 times the CDF under the
first scenario plus 1/2 times
the CDF under the
second scenario.
So we take 1/2 of this plot
and 1/2 of that plot
and add them up.
What we get is a function that
rises now at the slope of 1/4.
Then we have a jump, and the
size of that to jump is going
to be equal to 1/2.
And then it continues at a slope
of 1/4 until it reaches
this value.
And after that time,
it remains flat.
So this is a simple illustration
that for mixed
random variables it's not
too hard to obtain the
corresponding CDF even though
this random variable does not
have a PDF or a PMF of its own.